in this video we'll be talking about
Western blot this is a detailed
explanation on Western blot Western blot
is a frequently used technique in a
molecular biology or biochemistry lab so
what does this technique detect this
technique can detect specific protein or
your protein of interest in a mixture of
protein or a patient sample so here is a
mixture of protein and our question is
whether this particular pink protein or
our protein of interest is present
within that mixture or not Western blot
is a technique which can give us this
answer and the way Western blot works is
the antigen antibody interaction so here
the protein of interest is detected by a
primary antibody followed by a secondary
antibody which is linked to some enzyme
so this is why Western blot is also
termed as immunoblot because it utilize
the principle of antigen antibody
interaction now let's talk about the
Western block workflow in details so
there there are broadly three sets of uh
step First Step would be protein
extraction from the cells or tissues or
from patient serum Etc and the second
step is separating the protein on a gel
and the third step is detecting the
protein using antibodies in that Western
blood workflow so these are the broad
steps so first step is the protein
extraction which is done from uh any
kind of cells or tissues using lces
buffer we'll talk about the lices buffer
comp position in a moment second step is
running the SDS Spade gel or
one-dimensional gel to separate the
proteins according to molecular weight
and the third part is transferring the
proteins all proteins from the membrane
from the gel to the membrane and later
on using that membrane to detect whether
our protein of interest is present or
not so these are the three broad stretch
steps and in each step we would focus
and understand the details so the first
step is basically SDS
page so in this case before we even
start the procedure we have to think
about the Step Zero which means
isolating the protein from the cells in
this case proteins has to be isolated so
we need to have a protein extract or
protein mixture and that is done using a
buffer known as ralis buffer this is the
composition of the ralis buffer which
has several components alongside this
buffer a proteas inhibitor cocktail is
also provided just to prevent the
degradation of the
proteins then next step is to run these
extracted protein mixture on a SDS page
one-dimensional
gel so here we load the gel in the
particular SDS SDS gel and then we wait
for some time we allow the gel to run
and the proteins are separated on basis
of their molecular weight so here since
we use only one parameter that is the
molecular weight of the protein to
separate them from each other this is
known as onedimensional gel
electrophoresis as
well so question is how this gel is made
the gel is made out of acrylamide and NN
methy bisacrylamide so these these
polymerize to form the polyacryamide gel
or page so in this case there is a gel
holding
cassette between these cassette there
are two glasses where you pour the gel
now the gel chemist the gel making
chemistry is as follows it uses
basically a free radical mechanism to
polymerize Tade is one component that is
used to accelerate or used as a catalyst
in this
process so if the free radical is
represented as r dot then the reaction
goes like this described here so just
remember that in uh Western blood or in
case of SDS page Gil making the
chemistry behind this is a free radical
polymerization
chemistry now the question is how the
overall like Which percentage of the gel
has to be made and it depends upon the
need for example we want to separate a
protein which is around 80 kilon or
let's say 120 kilodalton and in another
scenario we want to separate a protein
which is like 13 kilon or 22 kilodalton
so obviously we can see there is a huge
difference in the molecular weight now
based on this molecular weight different
types of gel or percentage of gel is
used for example for bigger protein if
we need to separate we used 10% gel that
means it has much bigger pore size
whereas in order to resolve smaller
proteins we need to use a smaller por
size gel like 15% gel a detailed catalog
of all these percentage and which
molecular ladder to be used can be
available by the manufacturer company
itself now let's see how proteins are
actually separated in the gel we need to
talk about the chemistry and the biology
behind that so Western blot sorry the
SDS space gel has two components to it
stacking gel and the resolving gel
stacking gel is a portion where proteins
are concentrated prior to their run in
the resolving gel and resolving gel is
the portion where the proteins are
really separated on basis of their
molecular weight so differences in the
composition of stacking gel and
resolving gel is is really important to
understand and this kind of system is
capable to finally resolve protein
according to their molecular weight so
let us talk about the percentage of the
gel so the stacking gel is broadly 5% so
it has very big pore size whereas
resolving gel could be variable for
example in this case 12% it could be
also 15 or 10% as well now the pore size
is obviously larger in case of stacking
gel the resolving gel has relatively
smaller pore size but it also depends on
the con concentration the ionic
strengths are different also the pH are
different so why there is so much of
differences and let's try to understand
that so imagine we are first uh putting
some SDS and beta markup to ethanol with
the extracted protein samples so in this
case what happens is if the protein has
positive and negative charges when we
code them with SDS it would have a
uniformly negative charge around them
this would allow this would ensure that
when the proteins are separated on the
gel they are solely separated on the
base of molecular weight not the charge
so now every protein is co by SDS and
negatively charged now if this is the
overall gel and the proteins are loaded
there and they the proteins are
negatively charged so they would be
moving from the negative electrode to
positive
electrode now there are also other
components in the buffer such as the
chloride ion the Glycine and also the
protein which are coated with SDS so a
first chlorine ion would move quickly
because it's negatively charged smaller
in size it would quickly move towards a
positive electrode then the protein
would move after that and lastly the
glycine ion would move at pH 6.8 it is
protonated so it is positively charged
so it would be lagged
behind so sandwiched between the glycine
ion and the chloride ion these protein
molecules move in a stringent Manner and
they all stack up before the resolving
gel it's kind of kind of like a
realigning the athletes near the
starting
line so now it's time for them to move
into the resolving gel now resolving gel
has a different pH always remember
because it has a pH 8.8 at this point of
time the chloride ion would be moving
very fast now the glycin ion also start
moving fast because at that particular
pH it is not anymore prot alterated it
has negative charge so it is now anionic
right that's why it move very quickly
now the protein would be moved
afterwards based on their molecular
weight so this is the overall function
of stacking and the resolving gel now
let's the final step two is to run the
gel so the gel is run around 200 Volts
for about half an hour always somebody
has to check for the gel while it is
running and when the die front actually
leaves the uh gel it is time to stop the
gel
after the gel is run properly it is
important now to stain the gel this is
how a unstained gel broadly look like
after staining with specific reagent
like Kumasi blue it would look like this
one can clearly understand there is a
molecular weight ladder on the right
hand side and there are specific bands
which corresponds to different type of
proteins present in this sample now the
question is which stain to use and what
criteria determines which stain we
should be using so there are different
stains which one can possibly use there
is Kumasi Brilliant Blue stain there is
silver stain there is ponu now silver
stain is very sensitive for example if
you want to detect proteins as low as 5
to 10 nanogram silver stain is the
choice Pono also detects at a level of
200 nanogram or
higher now there there are other stains
such as zinc stain cypro Ruby stain NY
red stain now each of these stains has
their own purposes own benefits and own
uh disadvantages a quick overview is
provided in this particular
chart now let's move slowly to the
Western blot because we have separated
the protein in the gel now it's time to
blot and detect whether our protein of
interest is present or not when we
separate the gel on a when we separate
the protein on a gel our protein of
Interest might be present might not be
present in the mixture as well it's just
a separation and segregation of the
protein on a gel now let's talk about
how we can transfer the proteins that we
have separated in the gel into a
membrane and this is done by electroblot
so here a pvdf membrane is placed on top
of the gel and then it is sandwiched
between layer of paper towels and then
it is moved into a gel holder casset
further this gel holder casset is uh
embedded into a buffer tank which has a
transfer buffer now this transfer
happens under the influence of
electrical field now we already know the
proteins that are present in the SDS gel
they have negatively negatively charged
because they are basically Co with SDS
so they would possibly move towards the
positive electrode right so they would
move from cathode to the anode and
that's what is done in this particular
step So eventually all the content of
the gel would be now transferred into
the particular membrane or the pvdf
membrane now then a blocking step is
performed it is done to prevent
non-specific binding of antibodies so
blocking buffer quats all the portions
of the membrane that is such that the
antibody does not non-specifically bind
to the membrane it should find the
protein of Interest always so blocking
solution is generally made up of nonfat
milk or Bine albine and this step
ensures that antibodies later on does
not stick to the
membrane now then ultimately uh protein
uh a primary antibody is added to detect
whether our protein of interest is
present or not if the protein of
interest is present primary antibody
should be detecting it like shown here
and if it is not present it should not
be getting
detected so obviously after primary
antibody adding the overall solution is
kept overnight in 4° centigrade in a
shaking condition so later on in the
next day the washing step is done to
remove and wash away all the
non-specific bound antibodies or other
interactions later on secondary
antibodies are also added secondary
antibody binds on the back of primary
antibod so obviously if the protein was
there primary antibody should be there
and the secondary antibody should be
detecting it and ultimately there would
be another washing step a couple of
washing steps which ensures the all the
non-specific secondary antibodies bound
here and there would be
removed ultimately we have to develop
the blot in order to develop the blot
there are different strategies there are
cetric strategies where the secondary
antibody is bound with a enzyme which
upon sub which upon giving substrate
would be converted into a color product
there are also chemiluminesence uh
detection where there is an
chemiluminiscent uh Pro converting
protein which would convert a substrate
into a product which would be
chemiluminiscent and then there would be
also fluoresence based detection where
the secondary antibody is fofor tagged
So based on the f for one can detect the
fluoresence coming out from that sample
so all these methods can be used each
methods has their own difficulties and
sensitivities widely used methods are
chemiluminesence and fluoresence
fluoresence methods are pretty sensitive
but also expensive so these gels are
actually imaged in a gel scanner or blot
scanner which has a Imaging system to
adjust exposure Focus
Etc so this is how one can get a picture
perfect Western blot now that let's now
let's talk about the applications of
Western blot in bit more details with
some examples so here are some clinical
applications and biomedical applications
it's a very widely used bread and butter
technique for biochemistry Labs so let's
say how Western blot can be used to
study cell signaling in a cell signaling
pathway you always know that there are
some proteins that phosphorate other
Downstream proteins and this is how
signaling Pathways go on so sometimes
phosphorilation is a readout of
activation of a signaling path pathway
so in this case how one can use Western
blood to detect these kind of scenarios
so one can really have antibodies again
un phosphorilated versus phosphorilated
conformation of that protein and try to
detect a ratio of these two from the P
from the particular
sample so let's say there is a mapk
pathway we know that there are Ras mapk
pathway involves RAF make Ark Etc so
phosphorilation of Ark is one of the
sign that mapin pathway is active ated
and this can be actually visualized
using Western blot so obviously if there
is more and more phosphor Arc then the
signaling pathway is activated right so
in this case in the blot you can see
when the liand is present there are more
phospho AR compared to the normal Arc so
Arc to phosphor ratio is a indicative in
this particular case of the signaling
activation now let's say another
signaling pathway involves let's say
nuclear receptors which upon Lian
binding move from the cytoplas m to the
nucleus so the question is how this can
be detected on a western blot so
obviously one can simply
um look for Lian versus no liand
situations and extract the nuclear and
cytoplasmic fractions using Ultra
sentation from those extracts one can
probe for the protein of interest in
this case this particular nuclear
receptor from from these extracts and if
somebody sees a enhanced nuclear
fraction or presence of that protein in
nuclear fraction and a reduction in the
cytoplasmic fraction that means what
that means the protein has translocated
into the nucleus in this case carefully
notice the cytoplasmic fraction when the
liand was absent there are more proteins
in the cytoplasm than the nucleus but
when the Lian was uh present the plus
sign look the cytoplasmic fraction has
reduced and the nuclear fraction has
increased instead that simply means the
protein has physically moved from the
cytoplasm to the nucleus so these kind
of research questions can be addressed
using Western blot these are very simple
examples that I I'm providing you for
your understanding so I hope this video
was useful if you like this video give
it a quick thumbs up don't forget to
like share and subscribe you can support
our Channel using super thanks which is
a heart shape icon present on the bottom
right corner of the video by clicking on
it you can pay via Paypal PTM or UPI see
you in next
[Music]
video